few civilians have been inside the
shelter where some 2000 immigrant
children are being held separately from
their parents dr. Colleen Crabbe is
president of the American Academy of
Pediatrics she visited a Texas facility
for children under the age of 12 after
her colleagues called her and said dr.
Kraft you need to get down here and see
for yourself what was happening dr.
Colleen Crabb
joins us she said just call me Colleen
but I'm gonna call you dr. Kraft tell us
what did you see I went into a shelter
that was designed for very young
children and walked into the toddler
room and very different than when you
normally see toddlers they're usually
running around and rambunctious there
were a number of very quiet children and
there was one little girl who was just
sobbing and wailing and eating her
little fists on the mat and staff were
next to what she's saying she was crying
she was under two years old and asking
for her mother what was she she was just
crying she couldn't be comforted the
staff that was there were trying to give
her books and toys but they weren't
allowed to hold her and they weren't
allowed to comfort her and is that a
role you can't hold a crying child I was
told that you couldn't comfort or hold a
crying try
and we all knew that this child was
crying because she wanted her mother and
we couldn't give that to her
so you just observed we just observed
yes what are the physiological and
psychological effects of what this has
on the children so when we look at what
happens to the stress response in human
beings and very young children when we
are stressed we have increased levels of
cortisol of our fight and flight
hormones and normally that helps to
protect us when there's a dangerous
situation in the instance where children
are separated from their parents the one
buffer they have against these
fight-or-flight chemicals is gone and so
these children are on a red alert all
the time and they're not able to buffer
these different hormones and what this
can do is disrupt the synapses and the
neurological connections that are part
of the developing brain can they recover
from this kind of trauma is just long
lasting trauma to the brain
this type of trauma can be long-lasting
and it's difficult to recover from this
we know very young children who are
exposed to this type of trauma go on to
not develop their speech not develop
their language not develop their gross
and fine motor skills and wind up with
developmental delays heard some describe
this and that there the rhetoric is very
heated right now the conversation is
very eated and I've heard some people
describe this as a form of child abuse
do you see it that way it is a form of
child abuse and as much as I respect our
president and the office of the
presidency I want to turn people's
attention to a picture that I saw in the
media about a week ago with the
president's daughter and grandchild
Ivanka Trump interacting with each other
yes and if you look at this picture you
see the joy between parent and child you
see the child who is responding to their
parents you see that child's brain being
built every one of our children in this
world deserve that same relationship
with their parents and the same
nurturing at the end of the day that is
what what I've learned too that is what
all these parents want it is and this is
what we know builds child health
builds up children and this is what
every parent wants for their child it's
what every child needs from their parent
or chief padilla saying though that some
of the criminals are getting in with the
children when you separate a parent and
child at the border and that child is
crying for mommy you probably don't have
a human trafficker all right dr. Kraft
thank you very much for joining us we
really appreciate you joining us - thank
you for now let's send it back to Alex
in New York thanks Gail it is it is so
important to underscore and for help to
help us all understand what the
immediate and long-term health effects
of this trauma are on these children who
are increasingly younger and younger and
younger as a result of these separations
babies and toddlers well let's put a
finer point of that on that which is
that of the 2,000 children reported by
the HHS that are being separated from
their families there are about a hundred
that are under the age of four yeah and
the care that they may or may not be
receiving without a parent there I think
is exactly what dr. Kraft is talking
about who's the head of the American
Academy of Pediatrics and we should just
note there are two groups here they're
the kids who come unaccompanied and then
there is this new policy which is the
children that come with their parents
that are being separated and that's what
we're talking about just to keep people
clear on the different camps here they
are being rendered unaccompanied minors